you you bring up energy security uh and
so i'm gonna butter you up a little bit
before we get into a big disagreement
about uh nato and ukraine and all that
because i do want to talk about
geopolitics a little bit
but i think this actually plays into
your motif more than anything else which
is
globalization it's the idea oh yeah we
can buy our electricity from this and we
can buy a steel from that and we can buy
and before you know it germany's
importing its gas from russia
and even if the west wanted to do
something there
yeah i mean you're being held hostage
yeah the just-in-time supply chain
don't vote brexit or you'll destroy the
just-in-time supply chain with a
just-in-time supply chain suits giant
multinational global corporations but
does away with any concept of nation
uh does it with any concept of a common
good
for a collective group of people in that
nation and this has been very much
exposed
the german thing's incredible but
utterly incredible there they were
saying brexit was funded by the russians
trump
you know is in putin's pocket it was
germany all the time
i mean they've made themselves wholly
dependent and
and that of course means that our threat
of sanctions
against putin
are completely and utterly hollow and
meaningless because he can hurt the west
far more than we can hurt him
so let's talk about geopolitics now look
i've just written a book called an
immigrants love letter to the west and
it's mainly about why i think what we
have is actually pretty good and we
should stop beating ourselves up about
it but part of my argument is also is
the more we focus internally the more
time we spent talking about you know
this comedian made this joke and now
we're all very upset for three days and
whatever
the more we take eye off the ball and
that's why china is expanding into the
south china sea it's getting bullish on
taiwan you see what's happened in hong
kong and russia likewise you know um
do you think
the west needs to rediscover its kind of
ability to project power around the
world because you seem concerned that
nato is expanding eastwards and all that
look look i think we've made some
massive geopolitical mistakes since
1990. you know the berlin wall had come
down
and we decided that nato and the
european union would expand ever
eastwards
you know empires that are struggling for
a role continue expanding it it's a good
it's a good way i know i know you're
just going to answer and i never
interrupt guess generally but let me
just put a small counter argument the
reason nato is expanding eastwards is
because estonia lithuania latvia and
ukraine feel terrified rightly so
because only 70 years ago the soviets
invaded massacred their elites took over
their country they don't want that to
happen again it's not some bureaucrat in
brussels that's making that happen it's
those countries
just because they want to join
doesn't mean it's a clever geopolitical
move for us to say yes i'm saying the
motivation for expansion is not look
if i was polish yeah i would have wanted
to join nato
if i was polish i'd have crossed my
fingers and voted to join the european
union probably
i get that
but let's just think let's just go back
a bit further
you know
go back over the last couple of hundred
years of the of the you know formal
existence
of nation states around the world the
concept of a buffer zone
is actually quite an intelligent concept
okay
in the case of nato
this
eastwards expansion
is has been a deliberately provocative
move
against a russia which has always been
paranoid
you know the cold war
russia was far more scared of us
than we were of russia
and and sometimes
if you want to resolve a conflict right
sometimes what you have to do
is to put yourself in the mind of the
other person
rather like solving that crossword
puzzle you've got to think you know
whoever wrote this what what were they
hinting at
so we know russia's paranoid we know
that the old traditional
you know encirclement idea invasion idea
of russia is something that motivates
them very deeply by the way i don't
doubt for a moment that putin does have
expansionist tendencies however here we
are as we sit here today
with 130 000 russian troops massed on
the border
he's making one key demand which is that
we say
that the ukraine will not join nato okay
we have anthony blink in the u.s
secretary of state boris johnson some
woman called liz trust who's become
foreign secretary god knows how but
anyway there we are and they're all
saying no no no no if the ukraine wants
to join nato they can i suggest right
now we say ukraine will not be joining
nato we do understand
the concerns in moscow about ever
eastwood expansion it has come to an end
and we now ask president putin to stand
his troops down on that border we remove
from him
his causes belie we take away from him
any possible reason that he could have
to mount an invasion and we remember
that by not doing this earlier
we've driven putin into the arms
of the communist chinese government how
blooming stupid can we possibly be there
is no
there is no advantage or interest to us
in ukraine joining nato if we make this
concession at this stage in the aim
of bringing peace do you know something
it might just work nigel
what if what would you say a few years
down the line when
russia takes the rest of ukraine
which it will do well if you want us to
go to the third world war if you want
them to join nato and same british
troops that's fine i mean look look look
i i am i am not saying
absolutely
i have a cast iron guarantee
that i can stop the outbreak of war in
the ukraine what i can say i've got a
much brighter idea than anybody else who
was sticking to the same formula they've
had for 30 years which i believe to be a
geopolitical mistake and one of the
reasons i say this
is in 2014 we had the orange revolution
in kiev
do you remember all the people in the
square
who were part of that coup
that brought down a democratically
elected leader of the ukraine yeah
that's where you're starting to live
maybe a corrupt country yeah
he may have been a corrupt guy but he
was a democratically elected leader
brought down by people in the squares in
kiev
waving european union flags because the
european union had pumped in
pre-accession
aid and it was the stated aim that they
wanted ukraine to join the european
union far from being an organization
that guarantees peace in europe i think
where we are today was provoked in large
part
actually by brussels and it's
expansionist tendencies we've made some
big mistakes here and i i made those
arguments back in 2014
to be condemned
by everybody that somehow i was putin's
puppet i'm not
i just think sometimes that concept
of buffer states is actually a brighter
thing to do
than the line that we've been pursuing
here's where i think there's a flaw in
your argument if with all possible
respect of course
i think the flaw in the argument is if
if if what we need is a buffer zone
why and if russia is so desperate to
have a buffer between itself and nato
why is russia expanding westwards
um because because he sees an historic
coming together of the russian peoples
and all the rest of it and we have to
make it clear to him
parallels there well let's take away
from him any possible excuse he can have
any validation he can have firstly with
his own population uh you know you know
and secondly with all the rest of us um
i think it's the right thing so what
would you like to do
so ukraine joins nato that's your that
that no no i'm not i'm not necessarily
suggesting that ukraine should join nato
i think what what i see is in the
broader geopolitical that's why i
brought china into this yeah the west is
weak and it's showing weakness well we
saw that in kabul last year didn't we
right
and
and the people who and you'll understand
this because you understand how the real
world works you know in in the west we
talk about you know equality and
diversity and and politic or whatever
in the real world people don't operate
on that basis they operate on land money
finance weapons technology spy
espionage exactly all these things
yeah exactly human rights
so
what this looks like from the outside to
me as i look at it from a non-western
perspective is the west is distracted
the west is weak and all the things that
we would always would have quite liked
to have done right if we you know if
you're china well yeah you want to
expand this way and you want to take
over hong kong anyone do this so from my
perspective it depends on what people in
the west want if you want to manage
decline of the west this is what you're
going to get i have a feeling if donald
trump was in the white house we wouldn't
see a little rocket man firing off all
these rockets i don't think china would
be quite as bellicose no about taiwan as
that that's my point no no i mean look
you know biden has been a catastrophe
um
the unilateral withdrawal from
afghanistan was a complete disaster
right and far from america is back
they've actually retreated away
and the west is now without leadership
but that's my point nigel by by
advocating for the position you're
advocating for
that's part of the same sort of well we
just need to you know appease these
people and instead of the west coming
out and going look
we are the world superpower we are that
we're not embarrassed about our values
our values are better than yours right
freedom democracy these are all good
things and we're we are going to spread
them around the world because this is
who we are and we are the strongest
thing if you think china and russia if
they were the dominant hegemony in the
world they wouldn't do that you're
insane no i know
i just see
that being seen to make something of a
concession
right now
gaining the
moral
upper ground in this whole diplomatic
standoff that is currently going on over
the ukraine when as i say it's in it
it's not in our interests for them to
join anyway if he still goes to war he
still goes to war
we'd then be much more united against
him because we would have been seen to
have done the right thing as it is we're
carrying on with a policy that's a
mistake
[Music]